>> So I'm going to make two rows of quarters.
[ Background Noise ]
Ok. Does this row have more quarters?
Does this row have more quarters?
Or are they the same?
>> The same.
Ok, now watch.
[ Background Noise ]
Now, does this row have more quarters?
Does this row have more quarters?
Or are they the same?
>> This one has more quarters.
>> That one has more quarters.
>> Yeah.
>> Why does that one have more quarters?
>> Because it's stretched out.
>> Yes.
>> Ok, so how many are in this row?
>> 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
>> Ok, how many are in this row?
>> So, are there more in this row?
This row? Or are they the same?
>> The same.
>> Yeah.
>> Ok. Ok, so we have two sticks.
Is this stick longer?
Or are they the same?
>> The same.
What about now?
Is this stick longer?
Or are they the same?
>> That stick is longer.
>> This stick is longer?
>> Yeah.
>> Can you tell me why?
>> Because you moved it over.
>> So now it's longer.
>> Yeah.
>> Ok. Tell me, I'm going to pour blue water into
each of these cups and you're going to have
to tell me when they have the same amount, ok.
[ Pouring Water ]
>> Ok, tell me when this one is the same.
>> The same!
>> The same?
Those two are the same now?
>> Yes.
>> Ok. The same.
[ Background Noise ]
>>The water is the same.
>> Good. Ok, now watch this.
We're going to take the blue
water from this glass
and we're going to pour it into this glass.
Now, does this glass have more water?
Does this glass have more water?
Or are they the same?
>> It has more water.
>> This one has more water?
>> Yeah.
>> Can you tell me why?
>> Because that one's higher than that.
>> That one's higher than that one, right.
Can you tell me does this
ball have more playdough?
Does this ball have more playdough?
Or are they the same?
>> That ball has more playdough.
>> That one has more?
>> Yeah.
>> Let's try and make them the same.
Two of the same size.
What about?
What about now?
>> They're the same!
>> They're the same now?
>> Yes.
>> Ok, now watch.
Now, does this one have more playdough?
Does this one have more playdough?
Or are they the same?
>> That one has more playdough.
Can you tell me why?
>> Because you smooshed that one.
>> Because that one's smooshed.
How about?
How about now?
Does this one have more playdough?
Or are they the same?
>> The same!
>> Are they the same.
Why are they the same?
>> You rolled that one back up.
>> Ok. Great.
Hm.
Ok. Did we share the graham crackers fair?
Is this fair?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Can you tell me why it's fair?
>> You have more than I do.
>> I have one.
>> You have two and I have one.
>> Is that fair?
>> No.
>> No. How about now?
>> Now that's fair.
Why is that fair?
>> You have two and I have two.
>> Yes.